everybody it's gary vaynerchuck yeah so
I was going to a wedding this weekend in
Jamaica congratulations to Gabi and Josh
and a very special day today happy
birthday mom I love you
everything I have is because of you you
are absolutely the most important thing
in my world along with everybody else
that I love like Lizzy and AJ anyway
something happened that I thought I
wanted to make a video about check this
out I did something and I didn't really
think about it
and then I thought about it and I said
you know what I need to talk about this
on video because I think everybody needs
this kind of character in their business
or in their lives not that I am plenty
of things I suck at but this one thing I
did I think I get this for my dad so big
shout out to dad I thought was kind of
interesting I was reading Wired magazine
and so this advertisement for
audible.com you know so you know just in
Wired page or something anyway you know
was talking about their new uh you know
happened just about their sites a great
site the audio book has been doing
phenomenal for crush' thank you so much
and I notice they kind of said oh
there's a lot of books in the background
I started looking and I was like okay
cool cool so Seth Godin linchpin awesome
awesome
Jason reads rework is down here it got
ripped I love Jason three big shadow to
him and you know what about the big by
Tom Peters I just talked with him the
other day and what would Google do by
Jeff Jarvis great guy and you know and
just all these nice little books Branson
I just did a talk with him and Oslo free
by Chris Anderson super freakonomics and
outliners by Gladwell kind of was
looking and I was like wait a minute you
know
shit's not in this background and so he
ripped it out and I folded it and I put
it in my pocket and up and and then I
put in my wallet I'm gonna put it back
there because that's how I'm wired I
think it's fascinating and I don't do
this all the time I mean I'm actually
not as competitive as I used to be but I
really think that one thing that is
looked upon as a net
now in our society where you know little
leaguers are playing and there's no
winner smart I don't know if you've
heard about this and this whole movement
and I respect that I don't want to
suppress or hurt any feelings but you
know we kind of done okay in this
society at least from a competitive
standpoint in certain things and I don't
know I've got to be very blunt and
honest I feel that if you don't have
somebody in your organization or in your
company that really is built and
completely driven at some level by
competition that you can't win then it's
something that a lot of people need to
consider and for me the fact that I
ripped out that article and the fact
that that really drove me and listen I
know my role I know my spot which is I'm
nobody who better than most of names
there and so that's why I'm not the ad
and I get it but if you don't think that
still drives me if you don't think that
ripping out that article purely
subconscious you know just kind of like
ripped it out said okay audible.com okay
you know that's the kind of stuff that
is absolutely the backbone of the
success that I have and I think it's a
great that needs to be respected more
and more importantly instilled in your
company and your business
it is okay to hate your competition in a
completely competitive standpoint you
can go afterwards and be friends and
sharing the same soccer team and be on
the same boards for charity but in the
trenches when it's game time you need to
want to crush completely completely
crush so it's all I got to say I also
noticed this I'm gonna give it away I
love all of you so much that leave
comments so randomly you'll get a email
for me somebody who leaves a comment on
this video today with your thoughts I'd
love to hear your thoughts on
competition good bad I will give this
Nokia to I don't know think about last
year it might be an outdated phone but
you're still gonna get it see you later
happy birthday mom I love you